a book like he’s preparing to tell a story.]
Welcome, dear viewers, to another Tale of
excitement and intrigue from the archives
of the SCP Foundation.
Today, we’re covering a peculiar story,
titled “Foundation Facilities and How to
Loot Them”.
Our story opens on Shock, a member of SCP-4799,
frantically running for her life.
SCP-4799, in case you aren’t already aware,
is a group of smugglers also known by the
name Mariachi’s Merchants.
Now the Merchants aren’t your average, everyday
under-the-table traders mind you, this group
is capable of trans-universal travel.
Stealing advanced technology from other universes,
members of Mariachi’s Merchants will then
sell these devices to turn a profit.
Each of these members, of which there are
believed to be seven, originally comes from
a separate universe outside of our own.
And Shock?
She’s one of their best.
Blaster in her hand, Shock ran down the corridor,
stopping at a T-shaped intersection, frantically
trying to decide which way to turn next.
The energy weapon in her hand was still warm
to the touch; she’d only just fired it,
down to its last twelve shots, thirteen if
she was lucky.
There was only meant to be one life form nearby,
the only other living thing in a two-kilometer
radius, but Shock had quickly learned that
she was far from alone.
Two… things wearing lab coats, things that
had perhaps once been human beings, were shambling
their way closer and closer to her.
The nearest door was locked, protected by
a keypad, but there was no time to hack her
way inside.
Letting out a growl, Shock turned and opened
fire on her pursuers, the pair of creatures
that hadn’t registered as life forms, but
were still, inexplicably alive.
Energy bolts spat from her blaster, disintegrating
them both in an instant.
Turning her focus to the nearby door, Shock
pushed a thin black device into the key card
slot, connected to a thin screen that controlled
it.
She grumbled about how what had seemed like
a simple scavenging mission had gone south
so quickly.
The planet appeared to be dead, at least from
the perspective of the Mariachi’s Merchants’
ship in orbit.
What was the worst that could have happened?
Turns out losing communication with her crew
for one, they’d been radio silent after
the ship was reportedly fired upon.
The Merchants had promised to come back for
Shock once they’d shaken off whoever was
shooting at them.
The facility she was trying to scavenge had
once belonged to the SCP Foundation, presumably
a long time ago, codenamed Site 101.
Built under a spacecraft launch compound,
it should have been a goldmine filled with
all sorts of valuable technology.
But so far, it didn’t seem like there was
anything left in the facility that justified
the dangerous trip.
The keypad flashed green as the door unlocked,
Shock collecting up her hacking device as
the door opened… and one of the creatures
appeared on the other side.
Reacting with incredible speed, Shock blasted
the creature into dust, cursing at its body
as it disintegrated atom by atom.
What were these things, and why did the Merchants’
sensors not read them as life forms?
She pushed the question to the back of her
mind, there was a time and place to contemplate
what could be classified as “alive”, and
this was neither.
Hurtling down the newly-opened corridor, Shock
headed towards an open office door.
Hiding as quietly as possible in the office,
making sure the door was secure enough that
those horrors outside wouldn’t follow her,
Shock took a moment to calm herself.
She sat herself down on a leather chair in
front of the dark wood desk that filled most
of the space in the office.
It had belonged to one Doctor Dwyer, according
to the computer that stood atop the desk,
which Shock began to hack into, once again
using her key card cracking device.
After about a half an hour of working through
some very sophisticated security software,
she eventually managed to force her way into
the computer and started clicking through
its files.
The first thing she uncovered in a folder
that was conveniently labeled ‘Important’
was an email from the O5 command to the director
of this abandoned, former Foundation site,
along with other high-ranking members of personnel.
The subject simply read’ Farewell’.
In the email, O5-7 mentioned that the last
of a number of escape ships had successfully
launched from Site 101 and arrived at colony
stations.
It seemed that some kind of war was imminent
and would ravage the entire Earth, leaving
nothing behind.
So, in their infinite wisdom, the SCP Foundation
had been using its vast resources to evacuate
its personnel off-world.
Meanwhile, the personnel of Site 101 would
stay at their posts, perhaps to repopulate
or rebuild the Earth after the impending war
had passed.
That email had been sent in the year 2217,
a whole eighteen years before Shock had arrived
at this facility hoping to raid it.
The next email in the folder was headed with
the word “Intruder”, sent just under a
month before.
A pair of Foundation security personnel, Officers
Sanchez and Metje, had happened across a breach
to the ventilation system.
According to their reports, it looked as if
someone or something had forced its way in
with some kind of metal implement.
Shortly after, a third officer, Officer Peterson,
failed to respond to a radio check, seemingly
going missing.
Security had been advised to travel in groups
and to engage any unknown entity with lethal
force.
Something had made its way into the facility,
and it had arrived just before Shock did.
Uneasy, still not sure what had happened here,
the dimension-hopping scavenger read on.
The third and final email entry had been sent
the day after the last.
This time, security had a better idea of what
they were up against.
Surveillance footage from within the facility
had revealed the intruder to be none other
than SCP-049.
It had claimed the lives of multiple security
officers, with two of them confirmed to have
become instances of SCP-049-2.
Being from a different universe, however,
Shock had no idea what an SCP-049 was, nor
did she like the idea of being trapped with
one.
Now in case you, like Shock, haven’t heard
of the infamous Plague Doctor, then here’s
a brief bit of context on SCP-049.
A tall figure, shrouded in long black robes,
a hood over his head with only a white, beaked
mask protruding from underneath.
These aren’t just parts of his attire though,
the SCP Foundation discovered that all of
the pieces of SCP-049’s outfit are parts
of his physical body, made out of muscle and
bone.
The Plague Doctor’s primary goal is to find
those he deems to be infected with something
he refers to as “the pestilence.”
If he ever senses this affliction, he will
attempt to make direct skin contact with the
person carrying it.
SCP-049’s touch is lethal, killing anyone
who comes into contact with him in a matter
of minutes.
You might think that’s all the Plague Doctor
does, goes from person to person, killing
them via touch.
But you would be wrong.
Once he has killed a victim, SCP-049 then
begins performing a crude, outdated form of
surgery on their corpse.
Using equipment he produces from his mysterious
medical bag, he injects a number of unknown
chemicals into a person’s carcass, eventually
turning them into an instance of SCP-049-2
- In other words, a zombie.
And that’s exactly what it had done to at
least two of the Site 101 security officers.
When Shock delved further into the computer,
examining some security footage, not only
did she watch a monstrosity in a shredded
security uniform shambling through a corridor,
but there was something else following it.
A figure, completely clad in black robes,
its face shrouded behind an eerie, beaked
mask.
Shock decided her best course of action was
to find out as much as she could about SCP-049,
then use the facility’s security cameras
to figure out the quickest route to find any
propulsion tech that the Foundation might
have left lying around.
She familiarized herself with the Foundation’s
extensive file on SCP-049, learning what the
Plague Doctor could do; the part Shock found
to be particularly unsettling was knowing
the entity could shut down an organism’s
biological functions whenever it made direct
skin contact.
Best to try and avoid him, she told herself.
Studying the camera feeds, Shock noticed the
SCP-049-2s, that had all been the former staff
of this facility, didn’t seem to move around
much unless provoked.
All she had to do was make it through the
corridors to a door labeled “Propulsion
Testing” without the “dash twos” noticing
her.
Sounds easy enough in theory, and it would
have been easier in practice if there weren’t
currently eight of the zombies standing in
her path to the testing room.
With a tight grip around her blaster, Shock
bolted from the office, barrelling at full
sprint down the corridor.
She already knew from watching the cameras
that the first of the SCP-049-2s was around
the nearest corner.
Opening fire, she went speeding past its remains
as it turned into a little more than a smoldering
pile on the floor.
Around the next corner were another two of
the creatures, dispatched as quickly as the
first with the bright blue crackle of the
energy weapon.
So far, so good, but Shock was already anticipating
seeing a group of five SCP-049-2s huddled
together, the next obstacle in her way.
Sure enough, she navigated her way through
the facility’s hallways towards them, making
sure she had the element of surprise on her
side.
She blasted the oncoming mob of zombies, screaming
as they were struck by the blue light of her
blaster, only to vanish, vaporized forever.
All except for the fifth and final SCP-049-2
instance.
Shock had fired her fifth shot too soon, missing
the last of the creatures.
She waited for it to close the distance between
them, hoping for a closer target, but the
monstrosity knocked the gun from her hands.
They scuffled, Shock pulled a fusion bomb
from her bag.
Wrapping the unstable energy cell in her coat,
she let the creature grab the makeshift bomb
from her, picking up her weapon and running
as the bomb detonated.
Exhausted, she reached the Propulsion Testing
room, injured after her fight with the “dash
two”, Shock had hoped her troubles were
over.
And for a moment, they certainly seemed to
be.
She had stumbled across a motherload of tech,
modified reality anchors and all kinds of
equipment that would be perfect salvage.
But then, from the shadows, something new
stepped forward: the Plague Doctor himself.
Shock drew her blaster again and pulled the
trigger, but the weapon was spent, sparking
in her hands as it failed to fire.
Frozen, she stared at SCP-049, and it stared
back.
Lowering her weapon, Shock tried to calmly
introduce herself to the looming, cloaked
anomaly.
“I’m Shock.
Nice to meet you…
You're… or rather, these people called you
SCP forty-nine, right?
You sure did a bang-up job of curing everyone
in here from the looks of things.”
For a moment, they talked.
SCP-049 had heard the Foundation personnel
at Site 101 talking of being the last men
on Earth, and made its way into the facility
to “save them” as he put it, ridding them
of “the Pestilence.”
Shock explained that the rest of the planet’s
surface outside had been severely irradiated
and that there was no one living up top anymore,
all while sneakily sliding pieces of expensive-looking
tech into her bag.
SCP-049 argued that there were still people
left on Earth, that Site 42 housed the very
last remnants of humanity.
But they had been untouched by disease, they
were pure.
But Shock didn’t care one bit.
Instead, she made a move nobody would have
expected, she offered the Plague Doctor a
lift.
The Mariachi’s Merchants would be coming
back for her soon, and their ship was able
to take them anywhere in the multiverse.
After pondering for a moment, SCP-049 asked
to be taken with them, to find where the rest
of the sick were, unwilling to accept his
work was done.
“As long as you agree to keep your hands
to yourself,” Shock told him, as a grey
orb appeared in the room, hovering above the
floor, without touching the ceiling.
It was time to leave.
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” and “SCP-049 - What Actually
is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
for more videos that definitely won’t give
you The Pestilence!
Seriously, we promise!